your music videos you found always loved
them but the last one in particular for
never worn white this is where you
revealed your your baby bump for the
first time
oh you must have known you were gonna
cause a sensation with that and to be
honest that was really early on so I
think half of that was Taco Bell yeah I
mean I thought okay what better way to
you know release big information big
news in my own life especially to my
fans who've been following me since I
was almost a teenager really and grown
up with me it's kind of like were we've
been on this journey together I thought
do it via music yeah well to say your
fans were happy for you is an
understatement
we've got some clips of fans themselves
seeing the middle one was excited
because he was in a womb so recently yes
yes these are very young children
actually I think we've got one more fan
clip
Oh
[Laughter]
larnice is the lovely baby name for a
girl alar nice sounds like that's been
taken babe sorry well I am a fat and
congratulations my love thanks babes
Alanis
[Music]